das sind wirklich spannende erkenntnisse
zum gehirn gibt es ein maximum was man
wissen kann und was passiert wenn wir zu
viel wissen und wie viel gigabyte hat
überhaupt unser gehirn fragen über
fragen die wir hier und jetzt
beantworten und die antworten sind
verblüffend klick zum science fiction
gibt es hängt die spannende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
und activity glocke nur dann verpasst er
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
und heute mit jakob von breaking lab
vielleicht habt ihr schon mal von steven
müller gehört er soll ein elektrisches
gedächtnis haben also ein fotografisches
gedächtnis alles was er sieht wird
abgespeichert nach einem einzigen
rundflug über new york über die skyline
von new york da war er angeblich in der
lage ein exaktes bild der stadt zu
zeichnungen hier vorher noch nie gesehen
doch ein wirklich fotografisches
gedächtnis ist das nicht denn auch er
hatte einige abweichungen zur realität
aber und das finde ich schon echt
beeindruckend er war sehr nah dran er
hat also ein wirklich außergewöhnlich
gutes gedächtnis
er ist nach eigenen angaben autist und
viele autisten zeigen einen sehr sehr
hohen intelligenz wert und so genannte
insel begabung auf der anderen seite
sind sie tatsächlich sehr kontaktscheu
was dazu führt dass sie oft probleme in
der gesellschaft haben die innere
begabung kombiniert mit der hohen
intelligenz ist für immer mehr
arbeitgeber besonders interessant und
viele autisten arbeiten zum beispiel im
bereich programmieren diese studie hier
die hat sich mit dem thema autismus und
intelligenz beschäftigt und gezeigt dass
familien die öfters autisten zur welt
bringen auch öfters landseitig gesagt
genieß hervorbringen aber in deutschland
sind nur ca 10 von 10.000 menschen
autisten wie sieht das bei uns menschen
ohne autismus aus wann ist unsere
festplatte da oben eigentlich voll
also wir haben ca 86 milliarden neuronen
oder nervenzellen im sogenannten n gramm
speichern wir unsere informationen
grammer das sind verbünde aus zellen die
miteinander synchronisiert werden und
diese verbindung die geschehen über
synapsen ein neuron kann 10.000 dieser
verbindung herstellen und jetzt wird es
richtig interessant diese infos die sind
nicht einfach wie eine datei dort
abgelegt stattdessen sind sie in einem
großen zusammenhang eingebettet das
ganze kann man sich eigentlich ganz gut
mit künstlichen neuronalen netzen
mit ki vorstellen die verbindung
zwischen den neuronen die verändern sich
die ganze zeit alle neuen infos haben
einen einfluss und dabei schwankt auf
gesagt die stärke der verbindung unter
diesen neuronen wir haben bei einer ki
gewichte und die werden auch immer
wieder neu berechnet wenn wir das ganze
trainieren und hier seht ihr
wahrscheinlich schon den zusammenhang
die wichtige eine empfindung ist desto
besser können wir uns diese empfindung
auch merken und super gut geht das zum
beispiel mit emotionen
deshalb ist es auch wichtig dass
information spannend vermittelt werden
an einigen orten bleibt das nicht so gut
schule und an anderen orten da klappt
das schon ganz gut
youtube ok ich versuche jetzt nicht
youtuber zu beweihräuchern schaut euch
mal diese studie an
dort wurde die nutzung von youtube bei
schülerinnen und schülern untersucht und
das interessante ergebnis die studie
legt nahe dass schüler auf youtube
besser lernen da die bindung zur person
die etwas erklärt stärker ist und die
infos interessanter aufbereitet werden
am ende von diesem videos ein video
verlinkt wo ich darauf eingehe und wo
ihr bei meiner eigenen forschung
teilnehmen könnt wo es genau darum geht
wie man auf youtube am meisten lernt und
damit hättet ihr die möglichkeit zu
beeinflussen die ich wie christoph wie
doktor watson und andere youtuber hier
ihre videos produzieren aber zurück zum
thema kann das gehirn jetzt voll werden
einige teile des gehirns werden
tatsächlich sehr schnell voll
unser arbeits und kurzzeitgedächtnis
sind schnell überlastet der harvard
forscher george miller hat in einem
paper geschrieben dass wir uns circa
sieben dinge gut für einige minuten
merken können sind die informationen
relevant genug kommen sie in das
langzeitgedächtnis aber dort herrscht
eine rege konkurrenz könnte man sagen
und besonders interessant dinge die sich
im gleichen themen bereich bewegen die
konkurrieren miteinander beispiel
passwörter haben wir fünf e mail
postfächer und nutzen zwei davon häufig
verdrängen sie nach und nach die
erinnerung an die passwörter der andere
zwei konnten
sprich das gehirn verliert alte daten
allmählich und kann so nie voll werden
dachte man lange tatsächlich es ist
forschern des max-planck-instituts
gelungen zu beweisen dass das gehirn
eigentlich nie etwas luft stattdessen
werden nur die verbindung der
es ist fast so als würde das gehirn eine
zip datei erstellen wo das ganze dann
komprimiert ist die zwar nicht direkt
geöffnet werden kann
aber welche entpackt bar ist deshalb ist
es auch einfacher dinge zu lernen die
man mal kannte mal gehört hat oder aber
wie 4 gigabyte passen denn jetzt in
unser gehirn lässt sich das überhaupt
berechnen laut dieser studie kann jede
synapse 4,7 bis speichern
rechnen wir also 4,7 witz mal 10.000
synapsen x 86 milliarden neuronen das
wären 500 5250 gb
das wäre jetzt recht überschaubar aber
eine neue studie von terry sinofsky vom
salk institute for biological studies
sagt wiederum stimmt alles nicht das
menschliche gehirn kann über zwei
petabyte an daten speichern
findet ihr seltsam dass die daten
abweichen dann hört euch mal dass sie an
also noch vor wenigen jahren da ging man
davon aus dass das gehirn etwa 100 mb
speichern könnte was damals
unvorstellbar viel war und heute
natürlich ein witz
und hier sieht man das große problem
daten werden im gehirn komplett anders
gespeichert als im computer im pc sind
das einzeln und nun also ganz doof
gesagt strohmann oder strom aus im
gehirn läuft das ganze über chemische
prozesse ab die vier komplexer sind und
das tolle daran ist man kann mit seinem
gehirn viel komplexere dinge machen und
man kann methoden lernen mit dem man
noch mehr lernen kann mehr dazu findet
ihr im video von jakob auf breaking lab
dafür hier klicken und dort könnt ihr
auch an seiner forschungen dazu
teilnehmen mit der youtube videos
optimieren will nach der auswertung
stellte die ergebnisse frei im netz zur
verfügung sodass alle youtuber davon
profitieren können und wir hoffentlich
bald gemeinsam die plattform noch besser
machen können vielen dank jakob bis dann
bleibt dran